[Music]
we are the descendants of an ancient
civilization one which mastered
technology mapped the cosmos and
understood our relationship with the
natural world our ancestors traveled the
world and built enormous structures they
scaled their Creations into cities they
shared a common governance and similar
religious beliefs our ancestors lived as
we do today as a global Society then
around
14,500 years ago this Global superpower
started to collapse first came
uncontrollable change and then a
cataclysm in less than a week everything
and almost everyone was gone those Left
Behind built monuments monuments not as
tributes to Gods who homage to Kings The
Monuments are a warning to Future
generations to us that warning is simple
danger is coming our civilization has
ended before and it will end again this
is one story that big archaeology and
World governments don't want you to know
because once you hear it you'll never
trust them again because the danger
that's coming there's not a thing they
can do to stop
[Music]
it yeah human perfect look I need your
help it's an emergency of course you do
aren't you supposed to be here look I'm
at I'm trying to get it oh hang on
don't worry about that yeah right that's
nothing hang
on crap don't look at that don't look
all I'm trying to do is send a message
to my Uber I uh look look look I I I
need to borrow your laptop I keep
getting all
these oh I am absolutely not letting you
borrow my laptop again you remember what
happened last time we said we'd never
speak of that again the FBI came to my
house
now I'm not allowed within 50 ft of a
petting zoo no I'll be such a baby the
good stuff never happens at the petting
zoo wait what do you mean the good stuff
stop changing the subject I need your
laptop mine is
all listen you don't need my laptop just
download Opera no is that today's
sponsor well what gave you that
idea Opera is the faster safer smarter
way to browse you can syn your data and
send files between opera on Mac Windows
Linux iOS and Chromebook I love their
tab Island feature which helps me stay
organized and focused when I'm doing
research yeah but how does that help me
with the my uh issue well opera has a
built-in ad blocker with no extensions
needed it also has a built-in VPN free
and unlimited that blocks your location
and doesn't log your activity or collect
your information and you can download it
all for free that sounds perfect yep
Opera has a bunch of other cool features
too like integration with Facebook
Messenger telegram Spotify Apple music
and a lot more they just pop up in Opera
no need to leave your browser it also
has Arya built-in AI that answers your
questions and gives you real time
information you just highlight what you
need help with and Wham it generates
content based on your ideas on my ideas
oh I know I I I know what I'm going to
do I'm going to make my video stop you
right there just go to the link in the
description below and download Opera for
free today Link in the description I'm
on it Hey listen do me a favor and don't
mention this to Gertie yeah she doesn't
like it when I hey Gertie you're home
from the spa how was it honey no I
wasn't on the internet you know I would
never lie to you that was one time now
you're going to hold that over me
forever hey I don't get on you about
watching a kuuy derby do I I know that
there are breads but there's more to
someone than muscles you know look I I
got to go deal with this yes please I'm
begging you and don't get me started on
how often you talk about cly
[Music]
stes in 1994 German archaeologist Clash
Smidt was touring Turkish Neolithic
sites when he spotted a limestone block
poking out from a hillside the locals
call the area Potbelly Hill or in their
language gockley teepe Schmidt and his
team began Excavating the hillside
around the Limestone and though they
didn't know it at the time what they
discovered would change everything we
know about human history we've all been
taught the official story The Big
archaeology story of the origin of human
civilization Stone Age hunter gatherers
emerg from the last ice age and
eventually discovered farming these
people organized into settlements in
Mesopotamia the Fertile Crescent then
about 6,000 years ago the first
civilization was born ancient Sumer
Stone Age humans before suer were
primitive their most advanced technology
was stone tools at Quebec Tepe
archaeologists uncovered four man-made
Stone enclosures covering 100,000 square
ft of land that's interesting but there
was a problem the earliest parts of
gobec tee were built
11,600 years ago go that 6,000 years
before the ancient samarians were doing
anything now this didn't make sense at
all 11,600 years ago was the end of the
last ice age big archaeology said this
far back in time humans were following
the migration of animals they built
temporary camps or at most mud Huts
humans were not building enormous
permanent stone structures they didn't
have the knowledge they didn't have the
tools they didn't have the talent yet
here it was so the more they dug the
more things stopped making sense soon
archaeologists learned that the
enclosures weren't built at the same
time this indicates long-term occupation
of the site well how long well the
newest structure was built about 10,500
years ago that means gockley tee was
occupied for over a thousand years now A
Thousand Years doesn't sound that long
but in human history a, years is a very
long time that's enough time for the
Roman Empire to rise and fall and Rise
and Fall
Again the excavation of gockley tee
continued and from the perspective of
the scientific establishment things just
kept getting worse gockley teepe wasn't
haphazardly thrown together by Stone Age
Primitives it was built strategically
for a
purpose
the four enclosures are circular between
20 and 200 ft across and all are angled
toward the star Sirius Sirius is the
brightest star in the sky many cultures
throughout history built temples angled
at Sirius but not 12,000 years ago yet
here it
was over the course of 1100 years
sirius's alignment moved across the
night sky so the Builders of gcle teepe
created newer enclosures to follow each
realignment to build these monuments
required an understanding of astronomy
mathematics and Engineering a project of
this size would also require skills like
Community planning Administration and
division of labor big archaeology said
people during this time had not yet
acquired these skills yet here it
was within each enclosure are t-shaped
pillars some of them 16 ft tall each
weighing up to 10 tons 43 pillars have
been excavated so far but the gockley
teepe story is just getting started only
5% of the site has been uncovered recent
lar Imaging revealed at least 15 to 20
additional structures and enclosures
buried beneath the main site and there
are more than 200 additional Stone
pillars now about those Stone pillars
there's something very strange going on
engraved on the pillars are depictions
of humans animals and human animal
hybrids there are foxes lions scorpion
snakes boar wild donkey gazel there's
all kinds of things and the work is very
Advanced but the most advanced carvings
are on the oldest pillars as the psych
gets newer the designs get less
intricate it's like technology and
craftsmanship suddenly appeared out of
nowhere somehow 7,000 years before
Stonehenge and the Great Pyramids of
Giza were built and 6,000 years before
the invention of writing humans were
capable of building
this where did the builders get this
sudden knowledge diaki well the answer
to that question is controversial diaki
maybe the human story doesn't start at
the end of the last ice age like big
archaeology wants us to
think maybe before the last ice age the
Earth was home to an older and much more
advanced civilization
That civilization then taught the
Primitive local hunter gatherers about
mathematics and Engineering they also
taught these primitive humans astronomy
and told them to pay very close
attention to the sky these ancients then
told the local people their story of the
time before the ice age when their
civilization
flourished pillar 43 in enclosure D has
become known as the vulture Stone on the
vulture Stone there's a detailed carving
that tells the story of these ancient
people unfortunately it's also the story
of the end of the
world pillar 43 in enclosure D also
known as the vulture Stone depicts the
worst day in human history engraved on
the pillar are asterisms which are
bright star clusters like constellations
pillar 43 points to Scorpius now to be
fair to Skeptics every culture is going
to have different representations for
their constellations but look at the
drawing on the vulture Stone without a
doubt that is a scorpion when the
constellation Scorpius is lined up with
the night sky all the other drawings
fall into place each of them
representing constellations a sun sits
at top the vulture's wing in the design
showing its placement in the sky in
relation to the Stars if we use the
central Sun as a guide to line up the
constellations it reveals a star map and
every star map is a date
stamp take the Hoover Dam for example
engraved on the floor of the dam is the
exact configuration of the stars as seen
from that location on the day the dam
opened e why did they carve that in the
damn floor so if the structure is found
thousands or millions of years from now
archaeologists will know the exact date
the date the damn people made it right
damn good
[Music]
idea the vulture Stone shows the only
time in his history that this specific
configuration of stars could be seen
from gockley Tepe it was a 100-year
window between 10,900 to 10,800 BC about
13,000 years ago but wait this is more
than 1,000 years before gockley tee was
built so this tablet is telling a story
of something that happened in the past
it's the story of a time period commonly
referred to as the younger dras and The
Terror from the sky the chain changed
the face of the
Earth the Ice Age lasted about 2.6
million years most of the northern
hemisphere was covered by Miles thick
sheets of ice 30% of the Earth's surface
was covered by glaciers this sounds bad
but for the human race it was good sure
the climate was cold but it wasn't cold
everywhere most of Africa and the Middle
East were warm with plenty of plant and
animal life and the climate was
consistent for 2.6 million years
hominids had a nice stable climate in
which to evolve during this time Homo
sapiens modern humans emerged during
this time we were born in the Ice Age We
thrived in
it then the climate started changing
temperatures became warmer year after
year the ice sheets slowly melted sea
levels gradually Rose this would have
been a concern for the human
civilization but they were helpless to
do anything about it oh so you admit
that even if the climate is getting
warmer there's nothing we can do about
it well that's an open debate how dare
you then suddenly around 12,900 years
ago the earth got cold again not as cold
as before but cold enough that humans
understood how to survive and thrive in
these conditions this mini ice age was
essentially a return to normal but a
thousand years later this age of normaly
ended violently and suddenly
the ice sheets melted as they had before
but not over 2.6 million years this time
the ice melted in weeks there was no
time for civilization to adjust this was
the cataclysm and there's evidence of
this cataclysm in ice cor samples taken
from Greenland and Antarctica there's
evidence in sediment cores from the
bottom of lakes and oceans there's
evidence in organic material that's been
carbon dated but there's also evidence
of this disaster on pillar 4 43 the
vulture
Stone along with giving us a date the
tablet also depicts the commet impact of
the younger dras at the bottom of the
pillar is a headless man linking the
date to death there's also a snake
coming from the south this has been said
to represent three giant waves washing
over the Earth those could have been the
tsunamis that we know for sure happened
but pillar 43 is only a piece of the
story pillar 56 depicts more of the
younger dras impact waves crashing
animals fleeing now those are scary but
to me pillar 18 is the most ominous
depiction at gockley Tepe first of all
it contains the only word on the whole
site the word is God maybe you was
saying oh God we're going to die oh God
please save us I think it was saying
exactly that wait I was just joking well
I think something very bad happened and
this pillar is a plea for help oh my my
joke joke isn't very funny
anymore pillar 18 in enclosure D focuses
on the constellation we know as Aquarius
but when it was built the pillar was
probably centered on Taurus now if
that's true we now have a very big piece
of this puzzle the common anky was
discovered in 1786 and takes about 3
years to orbit the Sun anky is about 3
Mi wide not a huge Comet but not small
either the thing is it used to be big
bigger much
bigger it was part of what scientists
call a mega Comet 100 m wide and not
just made of ice but also glass metal
and rock about 20,000 years ago the mega
Comet broke up this is good right oh no
this is bad really
bad when the 100 mile Mega Comet broke
up it created an enormous debris field
now instead of one Mega Comet you've got
millions of smaller comets ranging in
size from grains of sand to over a mile
across when the earth passed through
that cloud of debris the people at
Quebec liepe would have seen a firestorm
of comets raining down on the Earth all
coming from the Aquarius constellation
just as is depicted on pillar
43 but here's the scary part we fly
through that same debris field every
year it's called the torid meteor shower
and it's caused a lot of damage through
the years and if you're watching this in
September October or November we're
flying through it right
now when gockley tee was discovered big
archaeology had no choice but to admit
they had underestimated the
technological abilities of early man by
ow about 5,000 years it must be a
mistake they said after all there their
grant money depends on them being right
no need to fund a search for let's say a
mummy in a pyramid that's not going to
be there but in 2019 more bad news for
the mainstream that year excavation
started at karahan Tepe about 40 miles
from gocke initial estimates say it
might have been settled before
gocke gocke seems to have been built for
a single purpose maybe a place of
worship or an observatory car hunt is
very different it shows obvious signs of
a structured Society now there are many
different types of buildings at karane
some could be shops or residences or
food storage vessels grindstones Flint
plates and all kinds of other objects
have been found at
karane these types of artifacts haven't
been found at GOC teepe suggesting the
two sites served very different social
functions but these places existed at
the same time so it's possible gocke was
a religious Center where karane was a
residential neighborhood or maybe a
shopping district and if that's true
there must be more settlements in the
area yet to be found there's more lots
more in 2021 the Turkish government
announced the discovery of at least 11
additional hillsides which contain
structures very much like gockley teepe
the hillsides make up a 100 mile ring
with gockley teepe in the center these
sites are known collectively as tasler
now instead of an area inhabited by
nomadic Primitives tasler is a
metropolis cyber was uncovered by
archaeologists in 2021 around 10 mi from
gocke cyber is one of the most complex
settlements in the area archaeologists
found communal buildings big enough to
seat 50 people there are communal Halls
covered with countless Engravings of
humans and animals to the south of the
communal buildings are ancient
residential homes the layout of each of
the tosler archaeological sites suggest
hundreds of thousands of people live
there permanently right after the
younger dras changed the face of the
world but there's a site discovered in
2008 about 180 Mi away which really
broke history and suggests tosler may
have been a capital in what was a very
busy region while digging a dam in the
area Engineers rediscovered the
settlement of banku Tara damn
Engineers look you don't have to keep
tagging that joke oh you don't like my
damn jokes
HH the banuk Tarla settlement is between
12,000 and 13,000 years old that means
it was built within the younger dest
cold period before the flood the
structure found has similar features
with gockley teepe and the structures
belonging to this period in the region
the building has a unique architectural
style shape and interior Arrangement
unique with these features we can say
that it is a temple that dates back to
12,000 years this is where the existence
of an ancient Advanced civilization
starts to become almost irrefutable
mukut Tara has all the things we find on
tasler private buildings public spaces
it's got storage rooms tools ornamental
objects it's got Mega and microliths the
people of boncuklu Tara were so Advanced
they even built a sewer system more than
130 skeletons have been found there each
buried with hundreds of thousands of
beads the manufacturing of beads proves
that there was a division of labor an
artisan class it proves that the people
had time for more than just hunting and
Gathering they had time to make art H
making beads is more of a craft than not
but I get you meaning so big archaeology
was wrong again very very wrong
this area of turkey shows that thousands
of people live there in organized
communities they built neighborhoods and
temples they had shops and large halls
for Gathering they had division of labor
they were experts at stonework they
understood mathematics and astronomy
they were talented engineers and this
was 12,000 years ago but where's the
evidence of people learning these skills
if the people at gockley Tepe were
putting up 10 ton Stone pillars 10 to
12,000 years ago shouldn't we see
communities learning these skills 15,000
years ago 20,000 years ago we should see
an evolution of technology that takes
thousands of years but we don't this
advanced technology just
appeared but that's not exactly true the
people in the area around gockley teepe
banuk Tarla and curch were taught this
technology after the great flood it was
a gift to them a gift
from the people of the
[Music]
sea mainstream or big archaeology gets
things wrong a lot of things gockley tee
shouldn't be there neither should Karan
teepe bukuku Tara or any of the other
settlements in the area we're told the
Great Pyramids of Giza are tombs built
for Pharaohs but no mummy has ever been
found in a tomb not one not ever but in
the Great Pyramid
we did find evidence that it might have
been used as an ancient power plant big
archaeology hates that idea now when I
was growing up we were taught that
Native Americans first arrived in North
America by crossing the bearing land
bridge in Alaska between 10 to 12,000
years ago this was called the Clovis
first model because some stone tools
were found in Clovis New Mexico big
archaeology wasn't even close on how
people got to the Americas or when the
Monte Verde site in Chile blew up the
Clovis model when it was dated to
14,800 years ago buttermilk Creek
complex in Texas was dated to about
15,500 years ago the Bluefish caves in
Yukon Canada have evidence suggesting
human activity as far back as 24,000
years ago plus there's hard evidence
that people from Polynesia in the South
Pacific traded with and mated with
tribes in guat Mala many years before
Columbus and they didn't cross the
bearing land bridge in Alaska they
sailed thousands of miles across the
Pacific Ocean this means they had
Advanced ship making skills and
seamanship they had knowledge of
astronomy and the weather you had to
make that trip they also had to have
balls of steel I would have preferred
that you said nerves of Steel but but
yeah they were
Brave big archaeology knows the mine
culture had a large population but they
were not considered to be very
technological olic Al Advanced but in
2023 researchers deep in the Guatemalan
jungle discovered a sprawling Mayan
civilization it covers more than 650
square miles and here's the crazy thing
the cities were interconnected by a
series of super highways and these
weren't just paths or dirt roads the
roads were elevated to allow for
drainage and even paved with white
Plaster the Romans get a lot of credit
for creating the first roads but the
Mayans beat the Romans to it by about
2,000
years they're the world's first uh super
highway system that we have what's
amazing about them is that they unite
all these cities together like a
spiderweb which forms one of the
earliest and first state Societies in
the Western Hemisphere so big
archaeology was wrong about Mayan
technology but they still had to get in
the last word mainstream said sure they
had hundreds of miles of roads but they
didn't have vehicles they just walked no
animals or people pulling carts they
just walked hundreds of miles big
archaeology said this is because the
Mayans didn't discover the wheel but
Mayan toys have been discovered that
have wheels big archaeology says the
Mayans never thought to scale them up to
put them on carts how do we know this
big archaeology says we know this
because we haven't discovered the
carts
oh but a year ago big archaeology would
have said there's no way the Mayans
could have built a highway system why
not well because we haven't found one
yet there it is Big Archaeology is quick
to take a lack of evidence at face value
regardless of common sense like there
was no such thing as the city of dwarka
the advanced and prosperous city in
India that was consumed by a great flood
that was all a myth then dwaro was found
and dated to the younger dasas there's
no such thing as Atlantis but it's hard
to explain the bimin road in the Bahamas
or the ancient city off the coast of
Cuba that could be anywhere from 6,000
to 50,000 years old there's no such
thing as Mew the continent that once
connected Greece to Easter Island yet
the languages from those two cultures
share about a thousand words and the
yagon monument off the coast of Japan is
right where Mew would have been there
was no such thing as Darren cuyu the
secret underground city that hid 20,000
people from danger for thousands of
years that was just a local myth the a
man tried expanding his basement and
realized it's already been expanded and
the lost city of Daren cuyu was
discovered and that's why big
archaeology says there was no Advanced
culture Before the Flood because there's
no evidence of it except there
is every culture has a flood myth long
before Noah built the ark a great flood
turned up in Mesopotamia in the Epic of
gilgames the ancient samarians Egyptians
Greeks Hindus they all have a legend of
a deluge that wiped the earth clean the
flood myth really is worldwide the Norse
have their own version of the Noah Arc
Story the Inca the Aztec tribes Across
America Japanese Chinese Hawaiian
Australian Aboriginal this is just to
name a few the list is much longer now
the Legends vary but they're all
basically the same plot people are
misbehaving so a flood is sent to wipe
them out and start over with a few
Survivor
now I don't know about the misbehaving
part but we're pretty sure the flood
really happened but some of the flood
Legends have a
Twist those Legends say that before the
flood there were Advanced civilizations
who flourished on their own continents
while primitive humans were still
figuring out stone tools Atlantis was a
powerful and advanced island nation it
was larger than Asia and ruled by the
the descendants of gods Atlantis was
prosperous and technologically advanced
but the people became corrupt prompting
the gods to sink the island into the
ocean in a single day and night of
catastrophic earthquakes and floods
Loria was a huge continent in the
Pacific Ocean Loria was home to a
spiritually Advanced civilization that
was sometimes Ally and sometimes enemy
of Atlantis and then there was Mew Mew
is a continent either in the Pacific
Ocean or Indian Ocean it was once
inhabited by an advanced civilization
the survivors of Mew brought their
wisdom and began the civilizations of
ancient Egypt and the Maya Atlantis
lorea and Mew are all similar stories in
that they were highly Advanced
civilizations all existed around 9600 BC
all destroyed by a great flood but in
all three stories there are a few
survivors After the flood waters recede
and their homelands are destroyed these
survivors seek refuge on the mainland
the people they find are kind but
primitive so the survivors grant them
the gift of civilization and when you
show up somewhere it's always polite to
bring something flour bottle of wine
civilization I agree that's just good
manners but it's at this time that
agriculture explodes across the Middle
East megalithic structures now appear
complex cities emerge all seemingly
overnight in Hindu matsa the form of a
fish and guides King Manu to reestablish
civilization in Mesopotamia aanas
emerged from the sea as half man half
fish a merid yep hey yeah ask him if he
has a sister will you aanas teaches the
samirian agriculture writing law and all
knowledge crucial for civilization quak
quad also associated with water brought
civilization to the Aztecs in Egyptian
Polynesian Japanese Chinese Norse
Hawaiian Native American there's a
Godlike teacher who comes from the sea
to help restart civilization and these
saviors or teachers or whatever you want
to call them they all appear after the
great flood at the end of the younger
dasas and they all transfer wisdom and
knowledge to the Primitive people that
they meet and restart
civilization and there is more evidence
the cultures around the world seem to
have been given the same
knowledge for example Sirius is the
brightest star in the sky every culture
knows about it but every culture new and
old refers to sirius as a dog or a wolf
in ancient Iraq Sirius was called the
dog star that leads in China it was
known as The Heavenly wolf Assyrians and
acadians knew Sirus as the dog of the
Sun and in North America native tribes
used largely canine terminology like dog
that follows mountain sheep or Wolf star
when referring to Sy ious most cultures
holding a reverence for the brightest
star in the sky is understandable but
all of them referring to the same Star
as a dog or a wolf that seems like a big
coincidence we don't believe in those we
don't and then seemingly out of nowhere
banuk Lara a bustling City appears in
turkey karane with its homes and halls
and magnificent art appears and gockley
tee is built an entire complex dedicated
to the are serious and within the
complex 10 ton Stone pillars that tell
the story of man the fire from the sky
the flood that swallows the Earth and of
civilization given a second chance the
pillars also offer a warning for future
generations for us all that has happened
before will happen
again the builders gave a symbols on
stones and told us to watch the sky they
showed us the constellations to study
they gave us the exact date of the last
disaster so we could prepare for the
next one because there's always a next
one the images carved in the stone
pillars could be a guide to ensure
Humanity's survival but if all that's
true why was it all intentionally
buried around 10,000 years ago the
people of gockley teepe took up a
massive project they filled in the
entire compound with stone and debris
then they covered it with Earth and mud
to make it seem like it was never there
there are two theories for why they did
this one to preserve it or two to hide
it an advanced Society destroyed by an
ancient cataclysm the survivors venture
out into the world spreading wisdom and
knowledge and sewing the seeds of
civilization then in an instant
agriculture explodes cities are born and
a new era of man begins just not the
first era of man not only is this a
great story it's one of my favorite
stories I read Graham Hancock's book
Fingerprints of the Gods in the 1990s
and I was hooked I've been an ancient
civilization junkie ever
since but is it
true well big archaeology says it's
absolutely not true but we've shown that
lack of evidence is proof enough for the
mainstream to say that something never
existed only when dragged Kicking and
Screaming to evidence of the great flood
do they finally acknowledge it and only
when gockley teepe is discovered does
the date of the first civilization get
pushed back then buuk Lara is found and
the date changes again and it may change
again and again so big archaeology was
wrong about how advanced the people of
the Stone Age were they were clearly
Advanced enough to build monolithic
monuments and huge complex cities it
appears as if this skill and Technology
comes out of nowhere we don't see older
smaller structures that show an
evolution of technology that leads to
something as magnificent as gockley
teepe the technology just appeared and
it appeared at the end of the younger
dras after the great flood so it must be
a transfer of Technology from survivors
of an ancient Society whose civilization
was lost beneath the waves but let's be
fair there was an evolution of
Technology leading to gockley
teepe Nan culture existed in the same
area about 15,000 years ago they were
unusual in that they settled the area
permanently there's evidence of
cemeteries architecture food production
animal domestication and burials with
elaborate Mortuary treatments the nans
built organized stone structures
decorated with art this is 2,000 years
before gole Tepe a am malaha was an aian
settlement built around 12,000 years ago
they too used circular structures like
those found at gocke prian culture goes
back to 23,000 years ago now it's rare
to find evidence of this culture but
it's not impossible there are Engravings
ornaments and beads that are older than
gockley teepe thousands of years older
the monoliths at gocke are impressive
but the nans also created huge slabs of
decorated Limestone not as elaborate but
they were made with skill and
craftsmanship cortie is another Mound
discovered in the Anatolia area of
turkey found there are pieces of very
elaborate Pottery carvings jewelry tools
and fishing hooks Corti teepe has been
dated from 12,400 years ago to
11,700 years ago so not only older than
gockley teepe this settlement existed
during the cold snap of the younger dras
now it is worth noting that cortic Tepe
disappears around the time of the flood
but before the flood people lived there
for a thousand years so there is
evidence of an evolution of Technology
not just with jewelry and Engraving but
even building large monoliths all
thousands of years before gockley
teepe one of the great Mysteries is why
go tee was deliberately filled in now
the working theory is the earlier
structures were pretty big and dug into
a mound an earthquake hit knocked
everything into the mound and made a
mess of things then everyone in the area
filled in the rest of the hole and built
newer smaller structures around the
older larger ones structures that were
designed to withstand earthquakes now no
one really knows for sure but it's a
theory that makes sense to me and there
are some issues with the dates as well
the date on pillar 43 the vulture Stone
that's 13,000 years ago that doesn't
line up with the end of the younger dras
so it's not describing the great flood
but that date does line up with the
beginning of the younger dras was there
an impact at that time too well there
probably
was it's believed that the abrupt
cooling 13,000 years ago was caused by a
series of events that happened at the
same time there are ice course samples
that show and impact
12887 years ago and that data is
accurate within 5 years and this
happened at the same time as a large
volcanic eruption in Germany this caused
the Earth to be covered in s which
caused years of Darkness meanwhile the
impacts disrupted the ocean currents so
everything got cold again not as cold as
before but still cold then about a
thousand years later another event maybe
another impact maybe a massive solar
event we don't really know for sure
but something did happen to warm the
Earth and melt the ice caps really fast
we do have evidence of cultures that
existed before during and after the
younger dras now did we debunk the idea
of an advanced culture before that
absolutely not I'm just trying to give
you the full picture there absolutely
could have been someone else here long
ago and we've talked before about how it
would take only about 10,000 years
before all evidence of the human race is
is gone but here's the thing about that
number civilization disappearing in
10,000 years assumes the Earth is
peaceful if one of these years the
tourid meteor shower threw a rock at us
like it did during the younger dras well
it wouldn't take 10,000 years to erase
our civilization we'd be gone in a
[Music]
day here's how it happens it's a Brisk
November evening maybe this year maybe
20 years from now it doesn't matter
every November the Earth passes through
the torrid meteor cloud and the earth's
sky lights up people gather all over the
world to see the event meteor watching
parties are common you and a few friends
decide to get together and see the show
the sky does not disappoint shooting
stars zip across the night's sky like
fireflies there are even larger comets
that streak by for a full second or two
before burning out and once in a while a
big one it's a fire ball that lights up
the sky and for a moment night turns to
day now everyone's heart races but
Fireballs like these are known to
happened during the tour shower people
remember the TDS of 2015 that year
Fireballs hit the earth in swarms in
2020 a Tor Fireball exploded over Japan
that sounded like a bomb going off that
one set off car alarms for
Miles you continue to watch the sky and
notice the shooting stars getting denser
thicker then a fireball then another you
feel a little anxiety but the tour
meteors have been happening your whole
life and they've been nothing more than
a light show then another Fireball this
one looks like it's close it vaporizes
in a flash of light so bright that you
have to Shield your eyes you and your
group of Sky Watchers giggle nervously
then 3 seconds later a crack then a Bo
so loud you feel it in your stomach
everyone agrees this was fun but let's
go home but now there's another Fireball
everyone turns to see this one is
different it's not really streaking
across the sky it's expanding somehow no
it's not expanding it's coming closer it
comes closer and closer and there's no
way to tell how big it is from where
you're standing it's like a mountain
made of fire just as p Panic sets in it
disappears Somewhere Over the Horizon
you let out a deep sigh you didn't
realize it but for the past 30 seconds
you've been holding your breath you and
your group are now frantically Gathering
your belongings that was more than
enough excitement for one evening you
even ask yourself if you even want to do
this again next year but that question
has already been answered for you you
just didn't know it yet Over the Horizon
where the fireball disappeared a ball of
light emerges everything is lit up like
the day no brighter than that it's so
bright everything is just white the ball
of white light grows larger and larger
and you feel something deep in your
brain that part of your brain that
evolved 2 million years ago that lizard
brain it sends you a single message run
you
run about 3,000 M away there is has been
an event the meteor hits and vaporizes
everything around the impact point for
Miles water Rock cities all vanish then
the shock waves start earthquakes
radiate out from the impact point over
and over again as the Earth reverberates
like a bell these earthquakes move
faster than the speed of sound they're
so powerful they disrupt the tectonic
plates of the earth that sets off a
chain reaction of earthquakes and
volcanoes across every major fault line
forget LA and San Francisco the San
Andreas will either eat or burn the
entire California coast then you've got
the Cascadia subduction zone in the
Pacific Northwest the Hayward fault the
calaris fault the Garlock the wasach
they all erupt from western Canada to
Baja Mexico is leveled everything within
20 mi of the coast crumbles into the sea
then the shock waves roll back around
the planet again and again and again
again the biggest fault system in the
United States is the New Madrid seismic
Zone the most powerful earthquakes in US
history have come from here when that
fault goes say goodbye to Chicago
Indianapolis St Louis and down to New
Orleans all gone crumbled on fire or
underwater the New Madrid fault connects
to the Ramapo fault in the East and sets
it off like a fuse Ramapo extends
through Pennsylvania New York and New
Jersey then the Charleston fault in
South Carolina goes next from Boston to
Seattle from Maine to Miami and
everything in between earthquakes Rock
the country over and over again and this
is happening everywhere in the world
then comes the wind a category 5
hurricane has wind speeds of 150 to 160
mph a cat 5 hurricane is going to seem
like a gentle afternoon rushing around
the planet is a storm with winds over
1,000 mph this is called the Air Blast
anything wooden is gone cars boats
people all gone only the sturdiest stone
structures could survive the wind but
most stone structures have already been
turned to Rubble by the earthquakes in
some places the wind lasts for 16 hours
and within the wind is everything
buildings cars trees everything it's a
food processor that pulverizes
everything for
hours what happens next goes is one of
two ways option one the rock hits solid
earth now if that happens heat and
ejecta cause wildfires for thousands of
miles around the impact Point radiating
out from the center is a fireball moving
at twice the speed of sound this
Fireball is hotter than the surface of
the Sun a land impact also launches
millions and millions of tons of ejecta
into the atmosphere in fact millions of
tons of molten rock will leave the at
atmosphere and go into space the rock
cools and forms a shell of debris in
orbit around the Earth no more space
station no more satellites the ejecta
that remains in the atmosphere blocks
out the Sun for months but it only takes
a few days for plant life to start dying
the entire food chain is disrupted
within a week and completely collapses
in a month all food is gone and that's a
land impact option two is an ocean
impact this
is probably
worse the rock hits vaporizes the ocean
water and collides with the Bedrock the
earthquakes begin like before but what's
really dramatic is the tsunami but it's
much more than a tsunami more than a
mega tsunami what this is there's really
no name for it a wall of water rises
about a mile and a half in the air the
water would be higher than the clouds if
there were clouds the shock waves and
Air Blast dissipated all the clouds
leaving only dark streaks of smoke that
turn the sky blood red the wall of water
extends in all directions it moves at
500 mph by the time it makes landfall
it's even higher as the water tears
across the land it collects debris every
object the water touches is captured and
becomes part of the wave within minutes
the front face of the wall is a solid
mass of debris moving hundreds of Miles
hour the devastation is Extreme as the
Earth reverberates the secondary waves
begin these are smaller waves compared
to the first but they're still hundreds
of feet high and they Pummel the coasts
over and over and over
again about 24 hours later the Earth
settles volcanoes continue to erupt and
there are thousands of earthquake
aftershocks but most of the violence is
over this is the worst day in in human
history but here's what's really scary
the scenario I just described has
happened many times so a question for
the Skeptics how much evidence of human
civilization would be left after this
type of event Skeptics say there would
be evidence of trash plastic and steel
but would there after the comet strike
the Fireball the shock waves the 1,000
mph wind the string of Mega tsunamis I'm
not sure how much of any anything would
be left after that now you would think
that this event would leave a mess of
debris across the landscape but it would
be nothing like that the land would be
pristine well pristine in a way from
Horizon to Horizon is mud nothing but
mud everything has been pulverized into
dust any object larger than a basketball
is buried under mud 1,000 ft deep big
archaeology says there was no early
civilization because because they
haven't found one or maybe they just
haven't dug deep
[Music]
enough there is evidence of an ancient
Advanced civilization in myths and
legends from cultures around the world
not just evidence that a civilization
was here but also how it was
destroyed the Book of Revelation
describes events that could be
interpreted as impacts and I beheld when
he had opened the th seal and low there
was a great earthquake and the sun
became black as sackcloth of hair and
the moon became as blood and the stars
of Heaven fell unto the Earth even as a
fig tree casteth her untimely figs when
she is shaken of A Mighty Wind and the
heaven departed as a scroll when it is
rolled together and every mountain and
Island were moved out of their places
Revelation
6 that sounds exact exactly like the
impact I described earlier the stars
fall to the Earth the darkness the
Mighty Wind and earthquake strong enough
to move mountains in Indian texts the
vdus and the mahabarata they contain
descriptions of celestial events and
weapons that have been interpreted as a
comet or meteor
impacts gigantic elephants burnt by that
weapon fell all around uttering Fierce
cries loud as those of the clouds other
huge elephants scorched by that fire ran
hither and thither and roared aloud in
fear as if in the midst of a forest
conflagration mahab harata book
Seven that sounds like molten ejecta
hitting the Earth and setting everything
on fire just like we'd expect the Lasco
caves in France are some of the most
famous cave art ever found one drawing
called the shaft scene features a dying
man and several animals researchers now
say this describes a comet strike around
15,200 BC petroglyphs all over the world
depict celestial objects with multiple
tals these have been suggested to
represent the torid meteor swarm this
Petroglyph from foresy County Georgia is
a star map it suggests a common impact
event in 536 ad ice cor samples from
Greenland confirm an impact sometime
between 533 and 540 that impact had
Global ramifications and cooled the
Earth over 5° there are more examples of
impacts and these are just the most
obvious ones and notice that they're not
all from thousands of years ago some are
from just hundreds of years ago the
tunguska event in 1908 is thought to be
a TD meteor that strayed from the debris
field these impacts happen periodically
and they usually happen in the Autumn
when we cross the tour debris field and
maybe that's the story being told on the
vulture Stone at gockley Tepe not the
story of what happened in the past but
the potential danger we face right now
the toured comets come every year
September to November this year the
toured comets Peak on November 6th you
can see them for yourself now sure most
of them look like shooting stars but
some of them are Fireballs that light up
the entire Sky now why does big
archaeology and every World Government
discount this story because there's not
a thing they can do about it
every time we pass through the tour
Comet Cloud we're playing Russian
roulette every year a new spin of the
chamber a new pull of the trigger now
chances are when we pull the trigger all
we hear is a click but there are objects
in the torrid Cloud that are a mile wide
so even though the chance is small there
is a chance a real chance that one of
those objects will find its way to us
and when that happens our civilization
ends once again and there will be only
only a handful of survivors the few
people lucky enough to hide in Mountain
caves and maybe those survivors will
create cave paintings or Rock carvings
describing this world ending event
however they do it they'll want to tell
our story and it's an important one
every year we take our chance with the
tours one year we're going to lose then
the only thing left of us our entire
civilization will be one more very short
story
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's eckle
fish you good this one has me a little
rattled I get it but NASA is keeping an
eye out for trouble oh NASA is on it
great now I feel better are you being
sarcastic of course I'm being sarcastic
this has been the wi files if you had
fun or learned anything do us a favor
like subscribe comment and share that
stuff really helps the channel and like
most topic we cover here today's was
recommended by you so if there's a story
you'd like to see or learn more about go
to the Wi files.com tips and if you like
a deeper dive into this story and all
the other topics we cover here make sure
you check out the podcast the yfiles
operation podcast is available on
Spotify Apple Amazon and everywhere you
listen to podcasts and if you need more
wi files in your life check out the wi
files Discord it's fun it's free and
there are lots of Wi-Fi fans on there
24/7 I think we just hit 30,000 members
special thanks to our patrons who make
this channel possible I dedicate every
episode to you and I know I say it every
week but I really mean it without your
support there would be no wi files and
if you'd like to support the channel
consider becoming a member on patreon
for as little as three bucks a month you
get access to all kinds of perks like
you see the videos early without
commercials get special access on
Discord you get early access to fun
products like the Heckle fish talking
plushy and you get two private live
streams a week just for you another
great way to support the channel is grab
something from the Wi-Fi store yeah grab
yourself a a heck ofish coffee mug and
then you can stick your fist in and then
you P yourself a delicious beverage and
then grab yourself a heck ofish t-shirt
and wrap that around your head like a
turban and and then you get yourself a
heck of fish tugging plushy fish and
tugging out a fish toy that's going to
do it until next time be safe be kind
and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
oh
yeah I play Bia scar 501 a secret code
inside the Bible said I
was I love my UFOs and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing like I should
but then another conspiracy theory
becomes the truth my
friends and it never
ends no it never
[Music]
ends I feel the crap cat I got stuck
inside M's ho with mkl truck I being
only true
aware did Stanley Cub Bri fake the moon
landing alone on a film set with the
shadow people
there throughout well aliens just fought
the smiling man I'm
told and his name was
cold I can't believe I'm dancing with
the
fish fish on thday night
J through the
night
all I ever wanted was to just hear the
truth to the one off through the
[Music]
night the MTH man sidings and the solar
stor still
to go the The Secret City
Underground mysterious number stations
planet to project Star Gate and what the
dark Watchers
[Music]
found a simulation don't
you the black KN satellite told me so I
can't for me I'm dancing with the fish
heck fish on thday night s they J and
W through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth so the Fe all through the
night fish on thday night Wednesday J
and through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth so I found feet all through
the dance good enough to dance good to
dance good enough to dance kie loves to
dancee loves to dance on the dance ball
because she is a camel when camels love
to dance when the feeling is right was
in time good love Dan good love
[Music]
Dan